Die, die davon profitieren,
sind Unternehmer,
sind verschiedene Politiker, sind
verschiedene Verwaltungsangestellte.
Alle, die ausserhalb dieses Systems
stehen, haben Nachteile.
Jeder Bürger, der Steuern zahlt,
jeder Private, der eine Gartenmauer
oder ein Haus baut,
die Gemeinden, der Kanton,
der Staat, alle.
* Langsame, melancholische Musik *
Und so entschied sich Adam Quadroni,
aus dem Baukartell auszusteigen
und die Preisabsprachen
nicht mehr zu akzeptieren,
die Machenschaften aufzudecken
und auszumisten.
Im übertragenen Sinn
kann man es fast so sagen, ja.
Ich hoffe, dass es vielleicht
ein bisschen geholfen hat.
Ich habe eigentlich nur
die Gabel reingesteckt,
ausmisten soll ein anderer.
Adam Quadroni,
früher selbst Bauunternehmer,
lebt heute von Hilfsarbeiten
und Zuwendungen.
Er hat den Behörden
die entscheidenden Hinweise
über die Bündner Baukartelle
geliefert.
Jahrzehntelang haben sich
die Unterengadiner Bauunternehmer
gegenseitig Aufträge zugeschanzt
und die Preise abgesprochen.
2012 hat das ein jähes Ende genommen.
* Langsame, gefühlvolle Musik *
* Ferne Kuhglocken *
Ab und zu hilft Adam Quadroni
bei August Koller aus.
Der Bauer aus dem Toggenburg
lebt schon lange im Unterengadin.
Er ist einer der wenigen, die
öffentlich zu Adam Quadroni stehen.
Der hat für August Koller
einen seiner letzten Aufträge
als Bauunternehmer ausgeführt.
Den Kontakt
hat ein Bekannter hergestellt.
Als ich die Scheune mit einem Anbau
vergrössern wollte, sagte er,
ich solle doch eine Offerte
bei Herrn Quadroni einholen.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Ja, ja, ist gut, schauen wir."
So habe ich ihn kennengelernt,
als er
mit seiner Offerte gekommen ist.
Wie war die Offerte
im Vergleich zu den anderen?
Ja, sie war viel günstiger.
Seine Offerte war gut 50 % günstiger
als die zweitbilligste.
Er hatte auch super Leute.
Das wurde alles perfekt gebaut.
Adam Quadroni offerierte so,
wie er es für richtig hielt.
Als er 2013 für August Koller baute,
war er längst aus dem System
der Bauabsprachen ausgestiegen.
Ja, an und für sich
finde ich es gut,
dass das mal aufgedeckt wurde.
Da gibt es ja viele Betroffene,
die im Prinzip am Ende zu teuer
oder viel zu teuer gebaut haben.
Von daher ist es sicher gut,
wenn es jetzt mal
ein bisschen Luft gegeben hat.
Ramosch,
das Heimatdorf von Adam Quadroni.
1'200 m ü.M., rund 500 Einwohner.
Unternehmens-
und Kulturberaterin Urezza Famos
kennt die Verhältnisse
im Unterengadin bestens.
Sie wurde hier geboren.
Auch wenn sie längst
im Unterland lebt,
ist sie beruflich und privat
eng mit der Heimat verbunden.
Adam Quadroni
kennt sie von Kindesbeinen an.
Er ist ein bisschen jünger als ich,
aber man wächst ja in
diesen Dörfern auf, man kennt sich,
man weiss, wer wer ist,
und von daher kenne ich ihn
schon sehr, sehr viele Jahre.
Er ist ein sehr besonderer Mensch.
Und v.a. kenne ich ihn auch
als sehr belesene Person.
Er ist ein Eigenbrötler.
Das habe ich auf eine Art
auch immer geschätzt.
Ich habe aber auch
ein Flair für Menschen,
die ein bisschen anders
in der Gesellschaft funktionieren
als der Durchschnitt.
Er ist ein eigener Typ.
Am Dorfleben nimmt Adam Quadroni
längst nicht mehr teil.
Er lebt völlig isoliert.
Viele haben sich von ihm abgewandt,
nachdem er das Baukartell
hat auffliegen lassen.
Er entschloss sich, bei den
Absprachen nicht mehr mitzumachen,
als sein erstes Kind geboren wurde.
Ich wollte
meinen Kindern beibringen,
dass man aufrichtig ist.
Wie kann ich das machen,
wenn ich das selbst nicht bin?
Das geht nicht.
Die Vorstellung ...
Ein Kind lernt z.B. Rad fahren.
Man kauft ein Rad,
und dann sieht man,
wie das Kind mit dem Rad fährt.
Und dann muss man sich vorstellen:
"Ich habe das Rad
mit dem Geld gekauft,
das ich ertrogen habe."
Und eines Tages kommt das Kind,
das wäre das Schlimmste, und fragt:
"Papa, warum hast du betrogen?"
Adam Quadroni
wohnt allein in seinem Haus.
Seine Frau hat ihn
vor zweieinhalb Jahren verlassen
und die drei
gemeinsamen Töchter mitgenommen.
Seither kämpft er darum,
den Kontakt zu seinen Kindern
nicht zu verlieren.
Es gab eine Zeit,
in der alles anders war.
Als Adam Quadroni 2002 heiratete,
nahm das halbe Dorf am Fest teil.
Die Familie Quadroni,
in dritter Generation eingewandert
aus Italien, gehörte dazu.
Das Glück des jungen Paares
schien perfekt.
Gleich neben dem Elternhaus
baute Adam Quadroni
sein eigenes, grosszügiges Haus.
Schon bald
kündigte sich Nachwuchs an.
Also, cun in Bericht quantas jadas
che es sta dret da telefonar ...
Heute hält nur noch
seine Schwester Jacqueline zu ihm.
Sie sind die beiden Jüngsten
von fünf Geschwistern.
Adam Quadroni
stieg nach der Maurerlehre
ins Baugeschäft der Eltern ein.
Seine Schwester
arbeitete ebenfalls dort.
Am Abend besuchte er jeweils
das Technikum in Chur
und machte noch einen Abschluss
als Baupolier und Bauleiter.
Die Baufirma Quadroni lief gut,
doch das hatte seinen Preis.
Adam Quadroni war Anfang 20,
als sein Vater ihn in den 90er-Jahren
zum ersten Mal an eine Versammlung
der Bauunternehmer mitnahm.
Er sagte zu mir:
"Jetzt zeige ich dir etwas,
das nicht richtig ist,
aber wir müssen das tun,
sonst überleben wir nicht."
Und das ist tatsächlich so.
Wenn man da nicht mitmacht ...
... hat man kaum Chancen
zu überleben.
Man kriegt kein Kies
oder zu überteuerten Preisen.
Oder der Transport ...
Sie geben einem die Lastwagen nicht
oder sagen: "Ah, genau zu dem
Zeitpunkt habe ich keine Zeit."
Es wird einfach boykottiert.
Und da hat man kaum eine Chance.
Ein Kleiner kommt da nicht raus.
Sie haben geredet, die Baumeister,
aber mir war nie so klar,
was da eigentlich läuft.
Als ich dann eingeweiht wurde,
worum es ging,
war schon erschreckend,
was da lief.
Und Papa war nie derjenige ...
Er hat das nicht gewollt.
Adam auch nicht.
Ihm war dabei nicht wohl.
Uns allen war dabei nicht wohl.
Aber man hat mitgemacht,
um zu überleben.
Die Bauunternehmer trafen sich
in einer Firma oder einem Restaurant,
organisiert vom Baumeisterverband.
Anfang Jahr teilten sie
Projekte untereinander auf.
Wenn ein Bau
dann ausgeschrieben wurde,
kamen sie wieder zusammen
und legten erstens den Preis fest
und bestimmten zweitens
das Unternehmen,
das den Auftrag ausführen sollte.
Vermeintliche Konkurrenzofferten
mussten höher sein
als der sowieso schon
überhöhte Preis des Unternehmens,
das für den Auftrag
auserkoren war.
Die Absprachen wurden bis ins letzte
Detail schriftlich festgehalten.
Wie viel zu hoch
wurden denn die Preise festgelegt?
20, 30, 40, 50 %,
auch bis zu 100 % mehr.
Aufgrund der Dokumente,
die Adam Quadroni gesammelt hatte,
leitete die Wettbewerbskommission
2012 eine Untersuchung ein.
Frank Stüssi begleitete
die Untersuchungen jahrelang.
Adam Quadroni hat damals
die Beweise auf den Tisch gelegt.
Er hat uns erklärt,
was im Unterengadin abläuft,
und er war der Auslöser
der Untersuchungen.
Wir haben gesehen, dass sich das,
was er uns gesagt hat,
bewahrheitet hat.
Also, wir haben anfangs
seine Glaubwürdigkeit geprüft:
"Stimmt das, was er sagt?
Passt das zusammen?"
"Sind die Dokumente stichhaltig?"
Das hat sich bewahrheitet.
Eine der umfangreichsten
Untersuchungen von insgesamt zehn
war Engadin I.
Die WEKO sprach Sanktionen
in der Höhe von 7,5 Mio. Fr. aus.
Den grössten Teil der Busse
von rund 5 Mio. Fr.
mussten Bezzola Denoth
und Foffa Conrad zahlen.
Hinter den Firmen
standen einflussreiche Männer.
Duri Bezzola, langjähriger
Verwaltungsrat der Bezzola Denoth AG,
ehemaliger Nationalrat.
Er will sich nicht
vor der Kamera äussern.
Roland Conrad,
langjähriger Verwaltungsratspräsident
der Foffa Conrad.
Bis 2014 sass er als Grossrat
im Bündner Kantonsparlament.
Auch er gibt kein Interview.
Foffa Conrad und Bezzola Denoth
gehören heute zur Testa-Gruppe.
Gegen die Verfügung der WEKO
haben sie Beschwerde eingereicht.
Die Bauabsprachen
seien nicht so lange
und nicht in dem Ausmass
durchgeführt worden,
wie die WEKO geltend mache.
Zudem seien Absprachen
lange gang und gäbe gewesen -
nicht nur im Baugewerbe.
Die Schweiz
hat bis Anfang der 90er-Jahre
zu den kartellistischsten
Ländern überhaupt gehört.
1996 wurden mehrere Gesetze
eingeführt, die damit brachen.
Dass etwas mal
erlaubt oder geduldet war,
heisst nicht,
dass man sich damit für späteres
Verhalten entschuldigen kann.
Ab 1996 war klar: Preisabsprachen
sind in der Schweiz unzulässig.
* Langsame, schleppende Musik *
Urezza Famos stammt
aus einer wohlhabenden Familie.
Als die Firmen Bezzola und Denoth
Mitte der 90er-Jahre fusionierten,
sass sie wenige Jahre
als Finanzgeberin
im Verwaltungsrat
des neuen Unternehmens.
Von den Absprachen
habe sie nichts mitbekommen,
aber sie beschäftigen sie.
Das hat
einen geschichtlichen Hintergrund.
Das Engadin ist ja nicht gross,
die Bauzeit ist kurz,
jedes Dorf hat ein Unternehmen,
das mit dem Bau zu tun hat -
nicht nur mit dem klassischen Bau,
sondern auch
mit den ganzen Nebenbranchen.
Man hat sich natürlich schon ...
Ich glaube,
es gab einen Gemeinsinn -
dass die Arbeiten gerecht auf die
einzelnen Firmen verteilt werden.
Aber mit der Zeit
und mit dem Volumen des Wachstums,
das gekommen ist,
und den Veränderung der Firmen
durch Fusionen und Käufe,
natürlich auch
durch Konkurrenz von aussen
sind die privaten Betriebe auch
immer mehr unter Druck gekommen.
Ich glaube, die haben sich einfach
aus einer protektionistischen Situ-
ation heraus zusammengeschlossen,
um zu schauen,
wie sie es verteilen können,
aber auch,
wie sie in der kurzen Zeit,
und das ist natürlich
dann auch so rausgekommen,
auch noch ein bisschen Geld
verdienen können -
und immer mehr Geld verdienen.
* Drängende, gleichförmige Musik *
Im Unterengadin
kamen die Bauunternehmer in Scuol
auch nach 2004 noch zusammen,
als das Kartellgesetz
verschärft worden war
und Gebietsabreden und
Preisabsprachen sanktioniert wurden.
Dieser Kreisel ist auch betroffen.
Er ist auch
in den Preisabsprachen enthalten.
Dort oben, die Bergbahnen.
Da ist das Swisscom-Gebäude.
Dort fanden sogar Sitzungen
über die Verteilung
von Swisscom-Aufträgen statt.
Dort unten ist das Altersheim.
Das Spital.
Die ganze Einfahrt
des Tiefbauamts hier.
So kann man
durchs ganze Engadin gehen.
Schon zu Beginn der 2000er-Jahre
sprach Adam Quadroni
über die Bauabsprachen.
Er sprach Grossräte an,
Angestellte des Tiefbauamts ...
... und Jon Domenic Parolini -
einen weiteren einflussreichen Mann.
Der heutige Bündner Regierungsrat
war von 2000-2014
Gemeindepräsident von Scuol.
Er liess Adam Quadroni
ins Leere laufen.
Quadroni hat lange, jahrelang,
darauf hingewiesen,
dass da etwas nicht stimmt
und hat den Leuten erzählt,
da fänden Preisabsprachen statt,
aber niemand hat ihm zugehört.
Und ich muss sagen,
er ist auch zu mir gekommen.
Ich habe ihm
auch nicht richtig zugehört
und wollte mich auch nicht unbedingt
auf das Thema einlassen,
als er kam und zeigen wollte,
was er recherchiert hatte.
Ja, denn er hatte halt
auch eine Vergangenheit
und er hatte auch
Opfer produziert, sozusagen.
Mit seiner Firma war er
auch nicht immer sehr geradlinig.
Tatsächlich: Adam Quadroni
geriet immer mehr
in geschäftliche Schwierigkeiten,
weil er nicht mehr bei den
Preisabsprachen mitmachen wollte.
Mit dem Bau eines eigenen Betonwerks
versuchte er,
sich unabhängig zu machen.
* Spannende Musik *
Es funktionierte nicht.
Die anderen Bauunternehmer,
sagen Quadronis, sorgten dafür,
dass sie nicht beliefert wurden.
Klar, wir wurden boykottiert.
Sie waren gegen uns: "Diese
Aussteiger müssen kaputt gehen."
"Die müssen wir jetzt vernichten."
Das Hauptproblem war dann,
dass diese Leute
z.T. zu meinen Kunden Kontakt
aufgenommen und gesagt haben:
"Bezahl den nicht!"
Wir haben auch gemahnt, wir haben
Zahlungsbefehle verschickt ...
Wir sind einfach nicht
zum ausstehenden Geld gekommen.
Es waren gewaltige Ausstände,
und wir haben es
einfach nicht reingebracht.
Sogar der Kanton zahlte nicht,
obwohl wir eine Bestätigung hatten,
dass wir das zugute hatten.
Das habe ich heute noch nicht.
Die Gemeinden ...
Warum haben Sie denn nicht die
Gemeinden und den Kanton betrieben?
Z.T. habe ich betrieben,
aber ich komme nicht weiter,
wenn beim Betreibungsamt
einer sitzt,
der ein guter Freund
des anderen ist.
Der Richter
ist selbst ein Unternehmer,
der am Tisch sitzt
und Preisabsprachen macht.
Die einflussreichen Männer
des Unterengadins.
Keiner nimmt vor der Kamera Stellung.
Sie haben sich
gegen Adam Quadroni gewandt.
* Langsame, tropfende Musik *
Aus Angst versuchte man,
ihn mundtot zu machen.
Man wollte die Kartellabsprachen
vielleicht einfach weiterführen
und nicht einen haben, der da
aus derselben Branche kommt ...
Das ist ein Nestbeschmutzer.
Es ist ganz klar, dass man
so einen nicht stützen will.
Da muss man
möglichst schnell schauen,
dass der mit dem Quatsch aufhört,
damit man weitermachen kann,
wie bisher,
denn man will ja
sicher nichts verändern.
Sonst hätte man ja etwas verändert,
wenn man das gewollt hätte.
Oder man hätte sich
an die Regeln gehalten,
wie es sich gehört,
aber das wollte man ja nicht.
Und das sind mächtige Männer.
Das sind keine kleinen Jungs.
Diejenigen,
die solche Baufirmen führen,
sind schon die Könige im Tal.
Sie haben politische Macht,
sie schaffen Arbeit,
sie sind grosse Arbeitgeber.
Sie haben eine Machtposition
im Wirtschaftsraum Engadin,
und wer die hat, hat Macht.
Dann haben sie vielleicht noch
interessante politische Ämter,
haben ein Netzwerk,
haben Beziehungen.
Das ist natürlich schon ...
Das ist nicht ...
Das sind starke Mächte.
Und der Bau ist eine starke Lobby.
Der Bau ist ein wichtiger Teil
der Existenz von ...
Viele Familien hängen daran.
2006 stieg Adam Quadroni nach einem
heftigen Streit an einer Sitzung
ganz aus dem Baukartell aus.
Drei Jahre später
nahm er einen weiteren Anlauf.
Wieder ging er
zum Gemeindepräsidenten
und zum Tiefbauamt
des Kantons Graubünden in Chur.
Beim Tiefbauamt
dachte ich zuerst ...
... anhand dessen,
was wir da besprochen hatten
und wie wir uns verabschiedeten,
hatte ich vielleicht das Gefühl,
dass da etwas passieren könnte.
Nach zwei Wochen war das vorbei.
Da merkte ich, dass das naiv war.
Bei Herrn Parolini
muss ich sagen ...
Während des Gesprächs wusste ich,
dass es ...
... umsonst war.
Jon Domenic Parolini
will sich im Film
nicht zu Adam Quadroni
und dem Baukartell äussern.
Vor zwei Jahren sagte er:
Wenn man sieht, welche Dimensionen
das angenommen hat,
wären wir rückblickend sensibler,
das ist ganz klar.
Da würden wir dann wahrscheinlich
weitere Schritte einleiten.
2009, nach dem Treffen
mit Adam Quadroni,
informierte er
sogar die Bauunternehmer.
So, wie Herr Parolini
dort reagiert hat,
war das grösste Problem ...
... dass er das jetzt
offiziell wusste.
Nicht, dass es vorkam,
sondern dass er es wusste.
Im Nachhinein müssen nicht
alle ankommen und sagen:
"Wir sind erstaunt."
Es kann niemand erstaunt sein -
sie haben es gewusst.
Man hat sie informiert.
Keine Stelle nahm Adam Quadroni
und seine Dokumente ernst.
Die Behörden
gingen den Absprachen nicht nach.
Adam Quadroni
wurde immer weiter isoliert.
Er konnte
das Personal seiner Baufirma
am Ende nicht mehr bezahlen,
aber er informierte sie
nicht rechtzeitig.
Ich kenne privat jemanden,
der heute noch auf das Geld wartet,
aber gleichzeitig
ist Adam Quadroni immer noch
mit einem teuren Wagen rumgefahren
und hat vermittelt,
dass es ihm gut geht.
Aber die Löhne wurden nicht gezahlt.
Das waren auch Familienväter.
Ich ging persönlich zu ihm
und sagte: "Zahl dem doch den Lohn!"
Ich wusste,
dass der das Geld brauchte.
"Ja, ich zahle.
Nächste Woche geht es."
Dann kam die übernächste Woche,
dann die dritte,
und gezahlt wurde nie.
Ich kenne jetzt
einen Fall ganz konkret,
aber ich weiss,
dass es noch andere gibt.
So macht man sich
auch nicht glaubwürdig.
Er hätte ja sagen können:
"Mir geht es nicht gut.
Ich kann euch nicht bezahlen."
Ich glaube,
er hatte nicht die Kraft,
einzugestehen,
dass er das nicht mehr konnte,
dass er es nicht mehr packte.
Meine Fehler
sind natürlich auch gross.
Ich habe das akzeptiert,
ich habe schrittweise mitgemacht,
ich habe es auch übertreten.
Sicher habe ich auch Fehler gemacht,
aus der Situation heraus.
Unter dem Druck, unter dem ich
gestanden habe, macht man Fehler.
Zu denen stehe ich auch.
Der Knall kam 2018.
Durch eine Artikelserie
im Onlinemagazin "Republik"
wurde die Geschichte des Baukartells
einer breiteren Öffentlichkeit
bekannt.
Ein paar Tage lang wurde Adam
Quadroni für seinen Mut gefeiert,
doch es dauerte nicht lange
und seine Integrität
wurde infrage gestellt.
Dass die Glaubwürdigkeit
von Whistleblowern angezweifelt wird,
geschieht häufig.
Deshalb setzt sich der ehemalige
Bundesgerichtspräsident Giusep Nay
heute für Adam Quadroni ein.
Solche Geschichten
kennt der pensionierte Bundesrichter
aus seinem Berufsleben.
Es geht ja meistens
um wichtige Persönlichkeiten
aus der Öffentlichkeit -
Menschen, die
in der Wirtschaft bedeutend sind,
die da angeschwärzt werden.
Menschen, denen alle vertraut haben,
die vollstes Vertrauen genossen,
und dieses Bild
von so einem Whistleblower
zerstören zu lassen ...
Das tun die Menschen nicht gern.
Statt die Tatsachen anzuschauen,
die er offenbart hat,
wird  e r  ins Visier genommen.
Adam Quadronis Glaubwürdigkeit wurde
u.a. deshalb in Zweifel gezogen,
weil er geschäftlich und privat
Konkurs anmelden musste -
nach Zahlungsausständen
und Betreibungen.
(Jacqueline Mischol) Es gibt welche,
die nicht gleich
mit dem Finger auf einen zeigen.
Sie trauen sich nicht so direkt,
etwas zu fragen,
aber man sieht,
dass da irgendetwas ist,
was sie gerne wissen möchten.
Oder man hört von einem anderen,
der hat jetzt das gesagt und ...
Man hätte auf mich zukommen
und mich fragen können.
Man hat schon gemerkt,
dass er ausgegrenzt wurde:
"Die haben Schulden gemacht."
Ein Konkurs ist ein Konkurs,
das ist jetzt einfach so.
Es ist nichts Schönes.
Das belastet mich heute noch,
weil es
immer noch nicht abgeschlossen ist.
Bei der Abwicklung der Konkurse
lief mutmasslich einiges falsch.
Erst langsam
kamen Ungereimtheiten ans Licht.
Bisher hiess es einfach,
Adam Quadroni habe selbst
Leute über den Tisch gezogen.
Was sagen Sie zu solchen Vorwürfen?
Dass sie nicht haltbar sind.
Es gibt keinerlei Indizien dafür.
Das ist aus der Luft gegriffen
aufgrund von dem,
was man bislang
aufgrund von Akteneinsicht weiss.
Es sind Menschen,
die Herrn Quadroni selbst
in diese Situation gebracht haben,
die ihm nachher
den Vorwurf gemacht haben,
er habe einen Konkurs erschlichen.
Dabei sind sie es, die ihn
in den Konkurs getrieben haben.
Also die Baumeister?
Baumeister und zugewandte Orte,
sage ich mal.
Adam Quadronis ehemaliger Buchhalter
reichte Strafanzeige gegen ihn ein
und erhob schwere Vorwürfe.
All die Dinge,
die ihm angedichtet werden,
haben mich hellhörig gemacht.
Und dann habe ich
Herrn Quadroni angerufen
und er konnte mir das immer
sehr plausibel und gut erklären.
Er hat so
aus meiner Erfahrung aufgezeigt:
"Aha,
das ist wieder die Konstruktion,
in der man schnell und zu schnell
gegen einen Whistleblower arbeitet."
Weil die Abwicklung
des Privatkonkurses
laut Adam Quadroni
von den Behörden verschleppt wurde,
konnte er diese Angelegenheit
bis heute nicht abschliessen.
Er zahlt einen hohen Preis.
Er hat nicht nur sein Geschäft
verloren, sondern auch seine Ehre.
Alles hängt damit zusammen.
Ich bin tatsächlich der böse Mann.
Das ist so.
Unter dem sozialen Abstieg
litt auch Adam Quadronis Ehe.
Hinter seinem Rücken
plante seine Frau,
ihn zu verlassen und die drei
gemeinsamen Töchter mitzunehmen.
Heute weiss Adam Quadroni, dass sie
sich an die Behörden gewandt hat,
weil sie sich angeblich
von ihm bedroht fühlte und sagte,
ihr Mann hege Suizidgedanken.
Damit setzte sie eine Kaskade von
dramatischen Ereignissen in Gang.
Am 15. Juni 2017 reinigte
Adam Quadroni sein Maiensäss.
Er war auf dem Rückweg nach Ramosch,
als er hier verhaftet wurde,
von einer Grenadier-Sondereinheit
der Polizei.
Ich fuhr hier entlang.
Ein Bus stand da.
Ich hielt an, und auf einmal
kam ein Haufen Leute an,
viele Polizisten,
Vermummte mit Waffen.
Schreiend.
Sie schlugen mich
durch das Finster hindurch,
zerrten mich raus,
rissen mich zu Boden
und stellten sich auf mich drauf -
wirklich sehr ...
... schlecht.
Die Polizei brachte Adam Quadroni
auf den Polizeiposten in Scuol,
wo eine Leibesvisitation
durchgeführt wurde.
Später wurde er in die psychiatrische
Klinik in Chur gefahren.
In Handschellen
und mit verbundenen Augen.
Bis nach Klosters
mit den Händen hinter dem Rücken,
und ab Klosters vorne,
mit Handschellen.
* Spannende Musik *
Die dachten wohl,
da komme weiss Gott was.
Zuerst schauten sie
ein bisschen komisch.
Während der Untersuchung
sagten sie immer öfter:
"Mein Gott."
"Das ist nicht zu glauben."
Als ich ihn
mit aufgeplatzter Lippe sah ...
Am Brustkorb
hatte er blaue Flecken, Schürfungen.
Er war also geschlagen worden.
Also so was!
Ich dachte: "Das gibt's nicht."
Ich dachte,
ich wäre im falschen Film.
Warum? Warum?
Das ganze Wochenende über
musste Adam Quadroni in der
psychiatrischen Klinik ausharren.
Nach vier Tagen wurde er entlassen.
Die Psychiater der Klinik Waldhaus
sagten,
er müsse sich bei der Hausärztin im
Nachbardorf zur Nachbetreuung melden.
Iris Zürcher wurde von den Ärzten
vorab informiert.
Herr Quadroni
hat mir diese Geschichte erzählt,
von dieser Verhaftung
durch die Polizei
und den Psychiatrischen Dienst.
Mir ist erst mal
der Unterkiefer runtergefallen.
Also, das konnte ich mir
überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Er wurde da wirklich eingeliefert,
mit Gewalt.
Auch die Umstände dieser Verhaftung
mit Handschellen ...
Auch die Psychiater haben offenbar
extrem gestaunt, weil das ...
Sie sind hier und da mal
mit einer fürsorgerischen
Unterbringung konfrontiert, aber so?
Das erleben sie selten,
mit Augenbinde und Handschellen.
Während Adam Quadroni
in der Klinik war,
zog seine Frau
mit den drei Töchtern aus.
Das war von langer Hand geplant.
Aus den Psychiatrieakten geht hervor,
dass sich die Psychiater
keinen Reim darauf machen konnten,
weshalb bei Adam Quadroni
eine fürsorgerische Unterbringung,
kurz FU, angeordnet worden war.
"Die Grundlagen der FU
konnten von hier aus
nicht sicher verifiziert werden."
Also, im Waldhaus,
in der Beobachtungszeit,
konnte man da
keine Anhaltspunkte finden.
"Vonseiten der KESB
konnten ebenfalls keine Hinweise
auf das laufende Verfahren
oder sachdienliche Hintergründe
gegeben werden."
"Es wurde von dieser Seite schon
im Umfeld der Einweisung mitgeteilt,
dass die Ehefrau
während des Klinikaufenthaltes
zusammen mit den Kindern
ausziehen werde."
"Wir wurden gebeten,
den Patienten übers Wochenende
in der Klinik zu behalten."
Iris Zürcher schrieb dem
zuständigen Regionalgericht sofort,
dass die enge Bindung
zwischen Vater und Töchtern
während der Trennung der Eltern
besonders geschützt werden müsse.
"Aus medizinscher Sicht
empfehle ich deshalb,
baldmöglichst einen regelmässigen,
gegebenenfalls begleiteten Kontakt
zwischen Vater und Kindern
zu ermöglichen und zu organisieren."
Wie wurde das
aus Ihrer Sicht umgesetzt?
Gar nicht.
Da ist ... Das ist ...
Darauf
wurde quasi gar nicht reagiert.
Das finde ich unglaublich.
Einen gewichtigen Anteil
an dieser Situation
hatte ein weiterer
einflussreicher Mann:
Orlando Zegg, Präsident
des Regionalgerichts Unterengadin.
Er führte bis Ende 2018 verschiedene
Verfahren gegen Adam Quadroni -
v.a. Konkurs-, Eheschutz-
und Scheidungsverfahren.
Angelo Schwizer
ist Adam Quadronis Anwalt
für die Konkurs-, Betreibungs-
und familienrechtlichen Verfahren.
Orlando Zegg
stammt aus einer Familie,
die im Transportgewerbe tätig ist.
Onkel und Vater Zegg sind ehemalige
Geschäftspartner Adam Quadronis.
Im Rahmen des Baukartells
waren Onkel und Vater Zegg
Quadroni jeweils
als Subunternehmer zugeteilt.
Zudem wurde die Kampfrichterwahl
ums Regionalpräsidium
von namhaften Leuten aus dem Bündner
Baukartell unterstützt,
namentlich Roland Conrad.
Für mich
ist es eigentlich undenkbar,
dass Adam Quadroni
im Rechtsstaat Schweiz
einem solchen Richter
gegenüberstehen kann.
Im Vorfeld des Eheschutzverfahrens
und im Rahmen
des Eheschutzverfahrens
hat Orlando Zegg vehement am Bild
einer Selbst- und Drittgefährdung
durch Adam Quadroni gearbeitet.
Die ganze Verfahrensleitung sei auf
Schikane und Zermürbung ausgelegt.
Adam Quadroni
müsse um alles und jeden kämpfen.
Ich habe
in einem Eheschutzverfahren,
wo der Gegenstand des Verfahrens
doch sehr beschränkt ist -
Unterhalt, Kinderbelange,
Zuweisung einer Wohnung -
noch nie einen
derartigen Aktenumfang gesehen.
In einem Schreiben an Angelo Schwizer
weist Orlando Zegg jegliche Vorwürfe
von Befangenheit zurück.
Vor der Kamera
nimmt er nicht Stellung.
Dass sich Adam Quadroni nach seinem
Privat- und Geschäftskonkurs
überhaupt Anwälte leisten kann,
hat er den Lesern des Onlinemagazins
"Republik" zu verdanken.
Unter ihnen war Natanael Wildermuth,
der kurz entschlossen
ein Crowdfunding für ihn startete.
An einer Feier im November 2018
erzählte er den Spendern,
wie er von ihrer Grosszügigkeit
förmlich überrollt worden war.
Ich habe gesagt:
"Ich will innerhalb von 30 Tagen
100'000 Fr. sammeln."
Und beim Crowdfunding ist es so:
Wenn man innerhalb der Zeit
weniger Geld sammelt,
wird alles wieder zurückgezahlt.
Wenn nur 80'000 Fr.
zusammengekommen wären,
wäre alles wieder
an Sie zurückgeflossen.
Darum ist es in dem Sinn
auch ein Risiko gewesen.
Nach 48 Std. waren es schon
50'000 Fr., also schon die Hälfte.
Und nach sechs Tagen waren schon
über 100'000 Fr. zusammen,
und das Kampagnenziel war erreicht.
Und am Ende sind für Herrn Quadroni
über 250'000 Fr. zusammengekommen.
Ich stehe für Gerechtigkeit ein.
Mir ist es wichtig, dass wir
in der Schweiz Gerechtigkeit haben.
Und zudem
liegt es mir sehr am Herzen,
dass es Herrn Quadroni persönlich
in Zukunft gut geht.
Das Schicksal von Adam Quadroni
bewegt viele.
Ich hätte nicht
für möglich gehalten,
dass alle mitmachen und schweigen
und nur einer aussteigt.
Wenn einer ein schlechtes Gewissen
hat und das aufdeckt,
muss man ihn
nicht noch schikanieren,
sondern man sollte ihn
vor der Politik
und den ehemaligen
Kartellkollegen schützen,
wenn man das so sagen darf.
Ja, ich finde das ziemlich schlimm.
Was Herr Quadroni gemacht hat,
braucht Mut.
Ich komme auch aus kleinem Dorf,
einer kleinen Talschaft
und weiss, was es heisst,
wenn man zur Seite geschoben wird.
Es wird schlecht über einen geredet.
Das ist nicht so einfach.
Ich bin
im Bündnerland aufgewachsen.
Ich dachte, es sei
ein bisschen besser geworden.
Darum bin ich sehr erschüttert.
Mit dieser Unterstützung
hätte ich nie gerechnet
und auch nie darauf gehofft.
Das habe ich auch nicht erwartet.
Es hilft mir sehr, sehr viel.
Ich kann nicht mehr sagen als danke.
Herzlichen Dank für alles.
Giusep Nay
sorgt beim Crowdfunding dafür,
dass die Einnahmen im Sinne
der Spender verwendet werden.
In erster Linie werden Adam Quadronis
Anwälte mit dem Geld bezahlt.
Giusep Nays Aufgabe
ist nicht immer einfach.
Als Erstes meldete sich
das Konkurs-
und Betreibungsamt Unterengadin.
* Lachen *
Weil das gesammelte Geld
nach den Regeln
der Crowdfunding-Plattform
rechtlich gesehen
Natanael Wildermuth gehört,
kann das Konkurs- und Betreibungsamt
nicht darauf zugreifen.
Wie erleben Sie,
dass so viele Menschen mit
Herrn Quadroni Solidarität zeigen?
Ich finde das überwältigend
und sehr, sehr wichtig,
v.a. für Graubünden.
Die Unterstützung
kommt ja nicht v.a. aus Graubünden -
inzwischen auch,
aber für einen Turnaround
in der Stimmung in Graubünden
ist das enorm wichtig.
Die Artikelserie der "Republik"
und die Verfügung der WEKO
erschütterten im Frühsommer 2018
den Bündner Wahlkampf.
Der Geschäftsführer des Bündner
Baumeisterverbands etwa
zog schon vorher
seine Kandidatur zurück.
Jon Domenic Parolini
schaffte seine Wiederwahl nur knapp.
Verschiedene Untersuchungen
wurden lanciert.
Die erste parlamentarische
Untersuchungskommission
des Kantons Graubünden
wurde einberufen.
Zudem setzte
die Bündner Kantonsregierung
Professoren und ausserordentliche
Staatsanwälte zur Aufklärung ein.
* Freizeichen *
Adam Quadroni versucht,
eine seiner Töchter anzurufen,
doch sie will oder darf nicht.
Davat ün telefon ün pa pü tard?
Ciao, ciao, ma bella. Ciao, ciao.
Nein.
Dass Telefongespräche
nur kurz oder gar nicht stattfinden,
kommt häufig vor.
Ja. Ach, Gott.
Der Kontakt mit den Kindern
läuft sehr schlecht.
Vom Regionalgericht
wurde im Urteil entschieden,
dass ich
dreimal in der Woche anrufen darf
und die Kinder uneingeschränkt
mit mir Kontakt haben können.
Das ist festgelegt.
Die Realität ist eine ganz andere.
Weder Adam Quadronis Frau
noch ihre Anwältin
noch die Anwältin der Kinder
nehmen vor der Kamera Stellung.
Im Eheschutzverfahren würden sich
die Auswirkungen des Whistleblowings
unmittelbar zeigen,
sagen Adam Quadroni und sein Anwalt.
Wo kann man Quadroni besser treffen
als bei dem, was er noch hat -
seiner Familie?
Da trifft man ihn im Innersten und
damit kann man ihn kaputt machen.
Regionalrichter Orlando Zegg
habe stets Partei für die Gegenseite
genommen, sagt Angelo Schwizer.
Da zeigt sich z.B. auch,
dass eine Beiständin und ein Richter
Kindesbefragungen
im Umfeld der Mutter machen.
D.h., man geht nach Hause zu Besuch.
Die Kinder leben bei der Mutter,
da kann ja niemand behaupten,
dass die nicht unter dem starken
Einfluss der Mutter stehen.
Nur schon die Gesprächsanlage
ist völlig falsch.
Üblicherweise
würden Kindesbefragungen
an einem neutralen Ort geführt -
in diesem Fall
z.B. am Regionalgericht.
Sicher nicht bei einem Elternteil.
Damit nicht genug:
Im Dezember 2017 lehnte Orlando Zegg
ein Gesuch um unbegleitete Besuche
der Kinder über die Feiertage ab.
Heute ist anzunehmen, dass er
auf dieser Basis versucht hat,
Adam Quadroni kurz vor Weihnachten
erneut
in die Psychiatrie zu verfrachten.
Hand dazu bieten sollte Iris Zürcher.
Am 22. hat mich das dann erreicht:
"Sehr geehrte Frau Dr. Zürcher."
"Aufgrund einer
vom Gutachter befürchteten
möglichen negativen Veränderung
von Herrn Adam Quadronis
psychischem Zustand,
nach Kenntnisnahme
des heutigen Gerichtsentscheides,
werden Sie als Hausärztin
und Psychotherapeutin
von Herrn Adam Quadroni
dringend aufgefordert, umgehend" -
und jetzt kommt das Fettgedruckte -
"die nötigen
Vorbereitungsmassnahmen zu treffen,
bzw. diese zu veranlassen."
Im Nachhinein
drängt sich so das Gefühl auf,
dass man gehofft hat,
dass ich da sage:
"Oh, bevor irgendetwas passiert,
und das an Weihnachten,
wo ich auch nicht da bin ..."
"Bevor irgendwas passiert, bevor
sich Herr Quadroni etwas antut,
weisen wir ihn lieber ein."
Dass ich ihn also wieder
in die Psychiatrie einweisen würde,
so nach dem Motto:
"Dann habe ich alles getan,
was ich tun konnte,
für meine eigene Sicherheit
und damit ich gut schlafen kann."
Dieses Gefühl hatte ich,
dass darauf spekuliert wurde.
Das Bild, dass Adam Quadroni
eine gefährliche Person sei,
hielt Orlando Zegg weiter aufrecht.
Die Eheschutzverhandlung ein Jahr
später im Gemeindehaus von Scuol
fand unter
starkem Polizeischutz statt.
* Schleppende Musik *
Im Unterengadin
stören sich viele daran,
dass Adam Quadroni den Weg
an die Öffentlichkeit gewählt hat.
Für die meisten
gilt er als Nestbeschmutzer.
Selbst Menschen,
die ihm wohlgesinnt sind,
ziehen es vor, zu schweigen.
Nicht ohne Grund:
Ein ehemaliger Kunde
von Adam Quadroni,
der sich vor der Kamera
äussern wollte,
zog seine Zusage zurück.
Er war bei einem Gespräch mit dem
TV-Team in Scuol beobachtet worden.
Daraufhin wurde er mit dem Ruin
seines Geschäftes bedroht,
falls er ein Interview gebe.
Als ich sagte, ich würde
das Interview mit Ihnen machen -
jetzt nur als Beispiel -,
haben alle gesagt:
"Ui, ui, ui! Du hast aber Courage."
Ich fühle mich
überhaupt nicht couragiert.
Ich finde das selbstverständlich,
dass ich mich hinsetzen
und meine Meinung äussern möchte.
Ich bin in dem Sinne
überhaupt nicht couragiert.
Aber es haben einige
die Hände verworfen und gesagt:
"Das würde ich nicht machen."
Und das finde ich
das Traurigste an allem.
Das muss ich sagen.
Es stimmt mich richtig traurig,
dass das nicht möglich ist.
Das Unterengadin und das Baukartell:
Hier möchte man einen Schlussstrich
ziehen und vorwärts schauen.
Die Gemeindepräsidenten etwa
drängen darauf,
dass der Kanton die Vergabe
von Bauaufträgen in der Region
wieder normalisiert.
2018 hat er Unternehmen,
die an den Bauabsprachen beteiligt
waren, keine Arbeit mehr gegeben.
Wir haben jetzt die Untersuchungs-
kommissionen, die arbeiten,
wir haben einen
ausserordentlichen Staatsanwalt,
der aufklären will und alles macht.
Wir haben das eigentlich.
Aber im Hintergrund sind
immer noch viele Amtsstellen ...
... die das Gegenteil machen.
Ich finde, man sollte das Thema
im Tal öffentlich mehr diskutieren.
Auch die Rolle der Polizei,
die Rolle des Richters,
es ist alles so ...
Man sollte Transparenz schaffen,
finde ich.
Das würde vieles aufbrechen.
Und dann sollte man sagen: "Okay,
daraus muss man jetzt lernen."
Aber was lernen wir daraus?
Indem wir alle schweigen,
lernen wir nichts.
Der Zwischenbericht der parla-
mentarischen Untersuchungskommission
von November 2019 sowie ein weiterer
Bericht rehabilitieren Adam Quadroni.
Es sei zu unrechtmässigen
und unverhältnismässigen Eingriffen
in seine
persönliche Freiheit gekommen.
Ebenfalls belegt ist,
dass die Polizei schon
ein halbes Jahr vorher geplant hatte,
Adam Quadroni zu verhaften
und in die
psychiatrische Klinik einzuweisen,
um seine Frau beim Auszug
mit den Kindern zu unterstützen.
Gegen Regionalrichter Orlando Zegg
läuft mittlerweile ein Strafverfahren
wegen Amtsdelikten.
Zahlreiche Untersuchungen -
auch die PUK - laufen weiter.
Für sie ist Adam Quadroni
weiterhin wichtig
als Auskunftsperson, aber auch
als Lieferant von Dokumenten.
Auf der einen Seite
bin ich sehr froh,
dass das jetzt gemacht wird.
Dafür habe ich
jahrelang gekämpft, ja.
Andererseits
kämpfe ich ...
... um das Recht an den Kindern.
Es sind sehr viele Baustellen,
und das macht einen ...
... schon halb kaputt.
Das ist ein Film,
der kein Ende hat.
Jeder schlechte Film
ist nach 90 Min. fertig,
aber hier nimmt es kein Ende.
Der geht nicht zu Ende.
Adam Quadroni hofft auf Gerechtigkeit
und v.a. darauf,
dass er seine Töchter wieder
ohne Einschränkungen sehen darf.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *